Now, can you know that you don't have H. Pylori?
Should I go through treatment protocol just to be sure?
So, first of all, go back to the website,
look at the videos and information I have on H. Pylori
and the importance of H. C. L. in your stomach
to prevent H. Pylori and to even help kill H. Pylori
and the things that you could do to help kill H. Pylori.
Should you test for H. Pylori?
Well, you can.
There is the Urea breath test for H. Pylori.
It's a thing that you breed into.
It's a kit that you can buy on a rippa store.
But it will only test positive
if they have H. Pylori on current,
H. Pylori on infection in your stomach.
There is a blood test for H. Pylori,
but typically the ones that are on the market are IGG blood tests
that will only test for past exposure of H. Pylori.
It's not a test for current exposure of H. Pylori.
There is a H. Pylori stool sample test
that's in the parasite,
it's in the Genova stool paracetology.
And I think it's in the mosaic paracetology lab.
And that test for H. Pylori,
that's probably the more accurate one.
But remember, that's only gonna test for what's in the stool.
Remember, H. Pylori can start in the stomach
and cause stomach ulcers, cause stomach cancer,
but it doesn't always just stay in the stomach.
It can get into the intestines.
It can go systemic in your tissues.
It is the cause of rosacea.
It's a cause of a lot of skin rashes.
It is the top four causes of endothelial disease.
Endothelial disease, heart problems.
So it could be systemic, and it most commonly is.
So I typically don't test for H. Pylori.
I don't even recommend testing for H. Pylori.
You really could diagnose H. Pylori,
certainly through kinesiology,
but certainly just through looking at your symptoms,
your symptomality.
And again, I've said multiple times that I personally take burberry,
you know, on a very regular basis,
because of H. Pylori,
you can't get H. Pylori, you look back to Pylori,
it's a bacteria that's a number one,
it's a systemic bacterial worldwide.
So it's not a matter whether you have H. Pylori or not,
it's whether it's active and causing issues with you.
So this is the reason why you'd want to be on
digestive enzymes and H. Pylori products
to help prevent, you know, H. Pylori infections.
So to answer your question,
should you just go through a treatment protocol?
Again, I take clear, pair of clear,
and I take burberry on a very regular basis
just because it's everywhere.
And just because you cleared it up,
doesn't mean you're not going to get it again next month.
So you're just exposed to it all the time.
Again, that's the importance of HCl.
I mean, your proper pH and your stomach
is to help digest your food, right?
But secondary, and maybe even a primary reason
to keep proper pH in your stomach,
that's very acidic is to prevent pathologies.
You're preventing a pathological infection of bacteria,
H. Pylori, just one of them.
So any food-borne infectious organism, including parasites,
should be killed by pH of 1.5 to 2.5 in your stomach.
So when you've alkalized your stomach,
drinking alcohol and water or just a poor American diet,
so your pridele cells, your stomach are up,
producing enough HCl.
And then you increase the pH of your stomach
even to 3.5, you are a cell yourself up for parasites
and H. Pylori and other pathogens,
other food-borne bacteria.